Hello everyone, this is the sound of the moment. Today
, I would like to introduce to you the points where you want to do 5 things with water.
Goo
First of all, you are the various casters of Street Fighter 5.
In Frey Life Prius, I introduced Birdie and Camie.
I think everyone thought that they were Birdie,
but we would like to do various things with files like this, so we will cut off the future development a little.  Please save it
.
First of all, it's a game system that you can understand by touching
it. The most important point this time is v system
.  I left this summer
Hey, I wrote in various pressure blogs now-I like the
detailed settings, but it is said that I can use this system. In
this place, it is called this card of 5 first.
I don't know if it's fun during the period, but it's a place, but
this herb is actually very Tsukui. It's an input system. It's a very simple command, is
n't it? I haven't been involved in this fighting game until now.
If you think it's a little help, you will definitely be able to master this boy system,
so
please come into the world of Tweet mitre 5 once.
Number Three
Izaba Mizu
is almost the first Street Fighter series this time.  I think, but I
will catch up with everyone's opinions with the data service
I would like to deliver it to everyone from July 23.
Until now, it was in Japan or in some places such as the United States.
I started with just that kind of help and didn't listen to some of the scribes' meetings, but
this time around the world, I'd like to hear the impact through this beta service,
so please join us
.
Regarding 4, first of all, it's an online system.
This Street Fighter 5 will be a big change from the current system of
4. Of course, we will also return to the matching system.
-There was a swivel chair that was often completed at that rug
. Still, it's even bigger. We have installed a new system that connects people who are difficult to communicate with each other,
so please come and
experience it through the data service.
I hope you can feel the Street Fighter Association Prius
labo Bai
As you may already know, Capcom has a year-round tour of each dark blue and black, of
course, this year 2015 as well.
I'm doing Capcom Black One all over the world, but
I'm thinking about this tour in the future with respect to this Street Fighter file
, so we're both in the process.
I would like to provide everyone with this professional, so I hope everyone will be interested in not
only watching the game from Cyan but also how
to connect the child to 5 and thank you for contacting me when I was in contact with 5.  I think
pablo